so the New York Times opinion editor
James Bennett just resigned for doing
his job and publishing a controversial
opinion the opening question is now
infamous the one where Republican
Senator Tom cotton makes his call to
send in the troops it argues for a
heavy-handed military response to any
George Floyd or black lives matters
protests where rioting and looting gets
out of hand
staff in the New York Times newsroom
were outraged that the New York Times
published the article and even though
they're not allowed to air their
opinions in public
many tweeted that it put black staffers
in danger that it endangered their
physical and mental health and that it
incited violence the publisher of The
Times said that the piece was
contemptuous and it shouldn't have gone
out but firing or hounding out the
person that's in charge of opinions
still feels problematic and brings up
questions about free speech and liberal
intolerance of opinions cotton isn't
exactly a marginal however much NYT
staffers may dislike it he happens to be
a politician with the ear of the
President
shouldn't the public know what opinions
he holds rather than be shielded from
them